you mentioned a bunch of innovation that
occurred uh in d5 and kind of crypto and
one of those is uh amms which obviously
is a core piece of the infrastructure to
make a lot of these decentralized
exchanges work uh my understanding and
uh you'll kind of correct me here if i
mistake anything but basically it's
taking the idea of the amm and the
liquidity pools and bringing that into
uh kind of a more institutional
regulated centralized type structure
with bullish talk a little bit about
that innovation around the liquidity
pools and the amms and like why is that
so uh effective and and so uh innovative
and then how you guys are thinking about
bringing this to uh you know more of a
wall street type audience first of all
typically the exchange with the most
liquidity wins um and exchanges tend
towards kind of oligopolistic market
structures not not one exchange
maybe more than two but you know not
making not necessarily more than 10 or
15 for for a particular asset because um
people like to have more liquidity
concentrated in in fewer places and what
liquidity means is
let's say i want to buy bitcoin or i
want to sell bitcoin or i want to buy
eth i want to sell it i want to know
for the amount that i want to buy
how much is it going to cost me meaning
when i buy it how much is the overall
market going to move against me
such that the market market value of my
asset is is going to be less at the
conclusion of my trade and in a perfect
world that that movement is zero
but you're never really going to reach
that theoretical zero there's always
going to be some cost because you have
to pay the people who are providing the
liquidity so exchanges all around the
world are in this eternal quest to be
able to effectively increase the number
of bids and offers that they can get in
particular around the current market
price
and whoever does that best wins and i
you know i remember just in anecdote way
back i don't even remember the year
maybe it was 2007
or eight uh i launched a new coffee
futures contract and i was all excited
about it
and you know i traveled all i went to
all these co i went to switzerland with
all these coffee guys like nestle and
everybody wanted it everybody it was a
robusta coffee contract they really
needed to be able to hedge their coffee
and then we launched it and it was just
crickets because the first person who
shows up to provide liquidity
they're gonna they're gonna end up
losing a lot of money and it's difficult
to find the market makers who are gonna
make markets in in coffee and so
i wanted to create our own liquidity as
an exchange i wanted to be able to
provide our own bids and offers but i
wasn't clever enough to figure out the
model that worked the model that worked
financially the model that worked with
the regulators and i had the same
experience later
launching a cds index product in europe
so on and so forth
and it wasn't until about a year and a
half ago when i started studying these
dexes
and in particular the the dexes that use
the amms most mostly powered by
something called the bancore algorithm
and the light ball went off i said aha
this is it this is like bring it you
know byob like br bring your own
liquidity as an exchange i can launch as
an exchange
and i can use this automated market make
automated market maker model which which
i use i use the term liquidity pools
synonymously so if i go back and forth
i'm talking about the same thing and all
of a sudden you have a way to populate
bids and offers and you're not beholden
to any one market make you're not
beholden to 10 market makers you're not
beholden to the same crowd of people
that are making the same prices and a
whole bunch of other exchanges
and just to go back 10 minutes when you
know when our guy elon puts out a tweet
uh and they pull back their prices on
every single exchange so if if if you're
just doing that you're not unique
you're not going to win this you know
eternal quest i talk talked about but if
you're
using an automated market maker model
all of a sudden you can have a unique
and differentiated form of liquidity and
so that's that's really what got me
excited hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time